صباح الاثنين تتمركز قوه عسكريه اسرائيليه
كبيره في حي الجابريات عند الاطراف
الجنوبيه الغربيه لمخيم جنين تمهيدا
لاقتحامه
ينشر الجيش الاسرائيلي قناصه على اسطح بعض
المنازل ليبدا الاقتحام بتوهل قوه الى
داخل المخيم
بالتزامن ترصد فصائل المقاومه تسلل عناصر
من المستعربين فتشتبك معهم لينطلق الهجوم
الواسع
نجحت الفصائل الفلسطينيه في محاصره القوه
المتمركزه في الجابريات والشبكه مع
عناصرها
واعترض مقاومون اليه عسكريه كانت تتحرك في
شارع الجابريات واعطبوها بمفخخه محليه
الصنع تقدر زينتها بنحو 40 كلغ
واستهدفوا مصفحه اخرى بقذيفه اخترقتها
بشكل مباشر واسفرت عن اصابه عدد من الجنود
الاسرائيليين
ترافقت محاولات فك الحصار عن القوه
الاسرائيليه مع اشتداد حده الاشتباكات
واضطر جيش الاحتلال لطلب تعزيزات وللمره
الاولى منذ عقدين استخدمت قوات الاحتلال
مروحيات عسكريه في قصف جنين ما ادى الى
سقوط قتلى وجرحه وقال الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ان سيارات عسكريه حاولت
الاصطدام بسيارات الاسعاف واطلقت الرصاصه
الحي لمنع نقل الجرحى اللافت في الاشتباك
من الجانب الفلسطيني دخول اسلحه محليه
الصنع بهذا الحجم حيز الاستخدام لم يكشف
عنها من قبل ومن بينها قذائف مضاده للدروع
وعبوات شديده الانفجار لتكون المفاجاه
الابرز اعلان الجيش الاسرائيلي اصابه
مروحيه عسكريه في العمليه واعطاب سبع
اليات مدرعه الاذاعه العسكريه نقلت ان
الجيش سيفتح تحقيقا لاستخلاص الدروس وقال
موقع ووالا نقلا عن مصدر في القياده
الوسطى الاسرائيليه ان قواعد اللعبه قد
تغيرت بعد هذه العمليه